[Music]
keith is kicking off this hour in
phoenix arizona keith welcome to the
ramsey show
uh thanks for uh having me and i
appreciate you taking the call rachel
and george um
my
wife loves streaming your show by the
way rachel oh
my question is going to be a rude one i
am at the end of a 17 year journey to
get debt-free in october uh
you know
literally the lion was outside the tent
door and he was hungry
honey we need to file bankruptcy or
something needs to change that level of
desperation keith what was that what was
the debt can i ask oh
house credit cards car the american
dream right you know
you know we were we were in our 20s and
early 30s and oh you need a new couch go
charge it you know that kind of uh
stupidity
uh in the process of that 17 years uh
you know we did the whole ramsey sold
everything we could sell paid off the
credit cards uh got the cars taken care
of
but you know
corporation uh moved five times got
downsized got kidney cancer
uh started a business so
we're the tortoise
we got there in october
my thing is i'm the leader of my
house for
17 years we've been running from the
lion
the lion's gone
it's like it you know we have these
discussions like what's next and oh well
maybe we should get a cabin and then you
know my wife and i are both free spirits
so that's another little hiccup in this
thing uh and you know my wife's on
realtor.com looking at cabins i'm like
well no we don't want to go back into
debt so it's kind of uh we're at this
weird place where you know
everything's good on hey get out of debt
do the steps get the 529 funded for your
kids we're doing all that stuff we're
doing really well
but
there's no what's next and after you
know literally first time in 30 years
we're debt-free
i feel lost sometimes i miss the lion if
that makes sense yeah so keith let me
get this straight you guys are in baby
step seven and your primary home is paid
for uh as of our 26th wedding
anniversary this october we paid it off
on the night of our 26th anniversary way
to go congrats keith it's a big deal and
i
i and
you say that with excitement and my wife
cried and it was beautiful but i've
known this was going to happen since you
know january february last year because
i knew where the money was coming from
but once again i
feel lost because i don't have a what's
next
and yeah i never thought i'd call you
guys and say that
you know well we get this call
we do get this call i would say on a
regular basis of this idea of whether
people have paid off they're already on
baby step seven or they're even on just
four five and six and i think how can we
have fun like we don't even know how to
do this
uh because it's gonna take some new
habits like you said you've been in the
habit
of
of running away from that lion and
paying off this debt and now there's
nothing and so
you guys need to sit down and you guys
need to have some goals and the goal now
is not paying off debt the goal is okay
what are we gonna do because there's
really three things keith that you guys
can do with money you can give it you
can save it and you can spend it so you
need to do all three
i would up some of your giving i would
look to see what can we be saving for in
the future what do we what's our 10-year
goal what do we want to have in
retirement do we want a cabin um you
know all of those and then
the part that's gonna be tough for you
guys or maybe not you're both free
spirits but to up that spending
uh lifestyle a little bit you know a few
percentage points and enjoy some of this
as well so
it's kind of a whole formula but i would
really really recommend keith you guys
sitting down my husband and i we do this
once a year and we look ahead and say
okay in the next three to five years
what are things we want to do do we what
do we want to give to
do we want to replace a car do we want
to you know go on a certain trip like
you can start planning out and having
goals out there
uh that is what your your your what's
next that's what that will be
yeah and like rachel's saying you kind
of need to plan for the fun and for the
free spirit to do that it actually is
super helpful so you don't feel bad and
you're not out of control in one area or
another you're not hoarding up money
over here saving for nothing because
you're just you can't stop but you're
not also spending out of control and
going back into debt and making some
unwise decisions so i would split it up
and go all right we want to do one fun
thing all right we're going to save up
for vacation we're going to go to europe
this year we know we want to buy the
cabin
okay we agree that's a five-year goal so
let's just save up to where in five
years we can pay cash for the cabin all
right we want to give this much and that
way you have a plan you can take a deep
breath and enjoy where you guys are at
this is a good problem to have keith and
i don't want it to cost anxiety for you
it's a blessing don't don't get me wrong
but like i said being the leader and
literally our focus i mean we paid off
almost 70 000 on the house just this
year to get to this point so we've been
hitting it almost as hard
now as a gazelle to get it finished as
we did when we first had the you know
the credit card debt and now there's
like nothing that's just unnerving in a
way so maybe i've changed i'm not as
much of a free spirit as i used to be
we've trained you
well and i think you can realize too
that life is you know there's there's a
quality of life that money doesn't have
to buy like you can be content with
maybe you know the lifestyle thing is
like hey we really don't need what we
thought we needed and we're kind of okay
with that like you know you're gonna get
to a lot of these conclusions and
and i appreciate keith your um
kind of intensity and motivation of
being that leader as you keep saying you
said that word twice in this call which
is great but i think too you know money
is such a team effort and i think you
know you and your wife have done a great
job being a team through that so
continue to be a team don't put all of
this on your shoulders
bring her in and you guys together say
okay as our family what do we want this
to look like and those conversations
once you get used to it and granted you
you this has only been 90 days for you
so you can take a deep breath you're
okay you're not you don't have to figure
all this out right now um but as you
really get into that new norm those
conversations are fun as a couple when
you say well we really have no payments
what is what's our next goal what do we
want to do and um it's a beautiful thing
keith i'm really proud of you guys yeah
and part of this is balancing that
contentment and goals it's great to have
both you can have a lot of great goals
and you can be very content with where
you're at and i think right now figuring
out that new balance is what's important
for you
i appreciate that we'll have to have a
family meeting and get our son in there
and
and and
work on this so yeah that's something i
like that idea of
having a fun goal and maybe some more
longer term things that we can shoot for
instead of just running from something
that's exactly i don't know who needs to
hear this out in america
getting cancer getting laid off
is so much better when you don't have
credit card debt and car payments i
can't imagine how we would have made it
uh so get through those baby steps fast
because life gets in the way beautifully
said teeth man what an inspiration way
to go man it's true enjoy baby step 7
life it's a good one